sweet dreams are made of this so I'm
gonna do something that I have not done
in a very long time and that is talk in
specific detail about specific comic
book property that I think not only
should be made into a movie but talk a
little bit about how I should do that
now I say haven't done that it's come up
a few times in roundtables I'm in the
last few months but it's been a long
time since I've just gone one-on-one
with you folks talking about a specific
idea a property that I think should be
made into a movie and I actually don't
even think it would be all that hard
so my pick for this time and I don't
know how many of these I'll do but
certainly on this go I'm gonna talk
about Neil Gaiman's Sandman this is one
of my favorite comic books ever done and
definitely it's right it's my second
favorite concluded comic book of all
time in terms of just the scope of it
the the tangents it takes the heaviness
of it the the power of stories which is
the theme I love this epic sprawling
tale from Neil Gaiman about the Lord of
the dreamworld is just an amazing piece
of work and it has been attempted to be
adapted to film repeatedly never getting
further than scripting stages even
though they have had different directors
attached at various points everyone's
always dropped off they can't seem to
crack this now before I get into this
and start talking specifics the first
thing I'm going to openly acknowledge is
if you were going to try and do the
entire series and basically be
all-inclusive about it it would have to
be a TV show you couldn't do that as a
film and the reason for that is that if
you haven't read Sandman I'll try and
avoid too many huge spoilers if that's
the case but there will be some towards
the end I'll give you a warning though
so the thing about Sandman is it has
your starting premise in terms of a
staff
who Morpheus also known as dream is what
his deal is and you know what it what is
that he he has to do some things that
impact his life but there's a ton of
tangental material there are some
stories where he basically appears as a
cameo at the very end and it's about
other people who simply are having their
own thing going on that it's somehow
impacted by it the dream realm which is
his realm or you have people just
sharing stories in which he is a tiny
part because like I said in many ways
this is a story about the power of
stories so if you wanted to include
everything the only way to do that is a
TV show because a TV show since you can
section off things in an episode and
just have it be that you can do
self-contained stories that don't impact
a greater overall plot and they can be a
one episode divergence and then you come
back to whatever else you're doing but
failing that failing a TV adaptation I
do think it is still possible to make it
work as a film specifically to make it
work as a trilogy of films now
everything I'm gonna be talking about
here is all story I'm not talking
casting I'm not talking directors I
honestly I don't have a good head for
that I don't indulge in fan casting cuz
I don't think I'm particularly creative
in that area I can never think of stuff
that I think is it was really like oh
that'd be awesome so I don't go there so
we are gonna start talking about what we
need to do to make this story work on
film and honestly I think to start it's
really easy you just start at the
beginning
pre ludes and nocturnes and basically
you do the story straight more or less
fun thing about Sandman is that its
first volume is the closest that it ever
gets to a more traditional comic book II
superhero narrative and that's by design
because it's the way to ease the reader
into this world before we get into the
much more abstract much more off the
beaten path much more unusual ideas
concepts and characters that get
involved later on down the line so that
first
volume is a story that translates pretty
much as is so what it is is you have
Morpheus being taken out of his dream
realm and captured by people who are
actually trying to capture and control
death the entity of death which happens
to be your sister his sister rather yeah
misgendering my goodness I should know
about it so that happens and then he's
trapped by this magic for decades and
eventually he does break out and there's
a little bit of taking immediate revenge
but then he now has to find artifacts of
his that were that also came with him
when they summoned him and they took
from him and then he has to go and
reclaim his realm the realm of dreams
which is fallen into utter disarray in
his absence there are dreams and
nightmares wandering around in places
where they are not supposed to be and
the whole thing is just a mess so it has
an initial strong inciting incident it
has a quest narrative and it has a final
villain in terms of who he has to face
down to get the last of the artifacts
that he needs which is his is Ruby now I
will have to get a little bit into
spoilers of this but I mean honestly if
you haven't read salmon please just go
read Sandman so what needs to change
because there are a few things the first
volume of Sandman is basically the only
one that had direct ties to the DC
Universe because after that it kind of
went off and did its own pocket
dimension kind of thing not like
literally it's not like they've got a
crisis thing on it but I mean they
didn't do ties anymore so those have to
go so that means we need to ditch the
Martian Manhunter thing that happens
which is a quick scene not a big loss we
do have to lose John Constantine and his
bit he's a little bit more integral and
honestly I'm a little bit sorry to see
that happen but I think the hassle that
you're gonna get from the hassle and
confusion that you're gonna get from
people who are they're then going to
expect more ties between this
other DC properties in future films
which is absolutely not gonna happen I
just don't think it's worth the trouble
to have the character appear so you can
honest well honestly you don't even
necessarily need him in that scene you
can still have Morpheus working alone
but you can have him doing any number of
things to get everything pulled together
he can be dragging along Kane or able
from his own realm for that little bit
he can you could have him dealing with
basically any Constantine esque
sort of supernatural investigative
character you can introduce the
character of hob early and have it be
him so there are ways around that the
big one that needs to change though is
the climactic battle and who he's facing
down for that because in the comics it
is the character of dr. destiny who's
kind of a d-list DC villain now the
thing is I'm this is not a case where we
have to change it because then people
will go oh so it's connected like it
will be Constantine because I don't
think anyone's scrambling for a doctor
destiny's inclusion in anything I think
most people who aren't hardcore fans
don't even know who that is but he is
still super villain and his use in the
story is still oh this was a super
villain he was in Arkham because there's
that shout out to and this was how he
had his powers he had you know this this
Ruby that was that that was Morpheus as
Ruby
so his background is still too steeped
in the in a world that has heroes and
villains of that nature so that doesn't
work so what you do instead is you get
is that you use a character who is
already in these stories is unique to
these stories is iconic as hell and
otherwise actually wouldn't be appearing
in the stories that I've selected to be
used across this this series of films
you would have it be the Corinthian the
Corinthian is an escaped nightmare who
fled to earth and became a serial killer
he is freaky so what you so it you don't
even have to really change anything
beyond that so you can roll with the
idea that he you know escaped the the
dream realm after dream was captured you
can even have parallel tracks going on
while dream is gathering up say his sand
and his and his helmet that the
Corinthian who has already been just
being a serial killer the more generic
type is is also pursuing the the Ruby
and he gets first so you can still do
that very unsettling diner scene with
the Corinthian instead of dr. destiny if
you don't want parallel quest tracks you
could have it that he already has it and
it may be harder to give the diner scene
that way because it's like well is he
just doing it now is he always doing
this kind of thing because he'll have
had it for a while but you can there
probably still ways to work around that
so that you can still include it or you
can substitute in something else that
will give equivalent unsettling feelings
about this guy so we get all that we
have basically the same climax the same
conclusion with dream ultimately
reclaiming his realm now I did say this
was gonna be a trilogy but it it is
important to me that that is the
entirety of the first film you don't
bother with a ton of setup for
everything else you tell that complete
story because it is a complete story so
that's where we start off then if it
goes well we do a sequel but what do we
do now there's ten volumes of this thing
but the thing is like I said beyond just
the issue of tangents and divergences
even the ones that focus on Morpheus
himself a lot of them don't have a
narrative that lends itself to film
there to loose there to meandering the
two will dream like they don't have a
clear beginning middle end they don't
have a clear inciting incident building
tension climax there are a couple of
stories that do though and my pick for
the sequel the next story to do would be
seasons of mist that's volume four now
in this one you have a situation where
Lucifer the devil
decides he is going to retire from hell
he closes hell's gates and he hands the
key to hell over to Morpheus basically
saying this is your burden now you can
do this what you will I'm out now he's
not necessarily expecting Morpheus to
suddenly run hell but by handing him the
key he knows he's handed him a world of
trouble because there's all kinds of
factions that have a vested interest in
what happens to hell after this
basically a whole bunch of deities just
show up at Morpheus door so this
includes things like the embodiment of
order and chaos this includes a group of
demons who are native to Hell who feel
that they should have control of their
own place this thing this includes Thor
and angels from heaven at being
representatives of God and all these
people saying you should give the key to
us and making a case as to why so and
also Thor Thor drags on Loki which is
fun and and these and these are the
traditional Norse versions of these
characters not necessarily the Marvel
versions but it's still a lot of fun so
you have your inciting incident with
hell getting closed down you have
building tensions as these various
factions are brought into one place now
it's it's fairly isolated it pretty much
all takes place just at dreams home as
these people make their case and the
tensions build and they pull various
sort of tricks or manipulations to try
and get what they want
it almost serves as a bit like a locked
door mystery and not in the sense that
like there's a murder that has to be
figured out but you're just watching
these machinations going on but it also
does have a climax because ultimately
dream does face down or one of the
attendees for this little event who
basically starts to break his rules and
it's a fairly quick battle in the comics
you could make it a little bigger for
the purposes of
not that hard to do and the only
potential issue on this is scope wise
there's a ton of implications of this
story but it is like is that fairly
isolated in terms of location but I mean
it's a dream realm you can have it be
shifting you can have things change a
bit more in accordance with Morpheus as
whims of course but I think that you
have enough freedom from that that it
does not have to feel like man this
whole thing is just set in this one
dudes mansion it doesn't have to feel
like that even though it potentially
could so that is your second one now
there's something else we've got to do
in this story
I would advise doing it as basically a
pre credit sequence and it's it's
unfortunately gonna feel slightly
detached and it's the thing I avoided
doing in the first film but you need to
do something that's kind of set up the
last one because for the last one to pay
off it's gonna take frankly way too much
stuff so we need to do something that's
a little bit of cleanup from last film
as well as setting up for the next one
now I'm feel safe in doing that in the
second film because if the first film is
successful enough that we're getting a
sequel it's a pretty good bet that we'll
be able to milk at least one more after
that so it's a bit safer to lay in stuff
that will pay off later down the line
and what that is is we have to set up
Daniel if you've read the series you
know who that is
so oh boy how to explain this long story
made as short as I can possibly do it
there was a woman who was pregnant and
basically sort of living in the dream
realm being almost the entire time that
Morpheus was trapped on earth and that
basically stretched out her pregnancy
and it kind of impacted everything that
was going on there and she was being
deceived by a couple of escaped
nightmares they weren't as bad as as the
Corinthian but this is basically like
loose ends that Morpheus has to tie up
he has to get his his servants back and
he has to get her back
into the real world which is something
that she doesn't thank him for because
in the dream world her husband's still
alive in the real world he is not so we
just had you you presented as Morpheus
tying up loose ends to establish her her
child which is Daniel and the tension
between the two of them the anger
between these characters so that's what
absolutely has to be set up here there's
one other piece that's gonna have to be
set up as well it could be done at the
tail end of seasons of mists of the
second film as well to have things be a
little bit cyclical in terms of parents
and parents and children and
relationships depending on runtime you
may also have to bump it to a pre credit
sequence to the next film but I think we
could probably squeeze it in here
because seasons amiss is one of the more
straightforward ones and it's one of the
more straightforward ones that allows
for trimming you just cut you just cut
down some of the some of the various
offers being made to Morpheus for the
key to hell so the other thing to tack
in here is the story of Morpheus and
Orpheus which is his own son now again
that's too long to do straight you
basically have to jump in at the end so
what I would advise is if there are
points across the middle part of the of
the film because you know you'll show
the various guests trying to persuade
more fees but also talking amongst
themselves and some of them could be
talking about Orpheus
talking about talking about their host
and this story about him and his son and
you know just sort of they're swapping
stories and this gets brought up and
then pays off at the very end now again
somewhat spoilers if you don't already
know this stuff ultimately Morpheus
kills his son and that's something that
happens quite late and after having
basically left him to suffer for
centuries because Morpheus is very
stubborn and can be very bitter and
holds a grudge like you
would not believe but eventually kills
the son because what his son wants his
son wants just to die and he grants him
that by the end so it's a confirmation
that these stories that these characters
were swapping about how heartless he is
becomes past tense like oh man he really
did just leave his sons alive head just
to be lonely but then he comes in and he
allows him to die and you realize oh
he's changing so that's your sort of not
post credit sequence but sort of
epilogue bit in the second film so
that's gonna get us to our third film
which is the kindly ones vol 9 if we're
going by the original trades so the
kindly ones is basically again spoilers
the death of Morpheus so we have a nice
full complete trilogy here now the stuff
that I said we have to set up had to be
set up because it impacts basically
where it what is going on with this
story so we had to set up um Daniel and
his mother because she is going she
through anger and fear directed at
Morpheus lashes out at him because she
is afraid that he will take her son and
she reaches out to the fates also known
as the kindly ones and they say he is
not mortal he is not even God he is an
endless he is one of the eternal endless
beings that must always be we can't
touch him unless he has spilled the
blood of his own family guess what he
did that by giving his son peace at the
end of the previous film done Ton Ton
and so they then empower her to go after
him and there is a bit more to it than
that as well because part of what sets
her off is Daniel gets kidnapped she
blames Morpheus who kidnaps him
Loki so in the comics it's actually Loki
and puck from A Midsummer Night's Dream
unfortunately I
I think there's a way to be able to set
up puck and get him into this story that
is not gonna eat up more time than it's
worth so I think you just have loki
acting alone rather than having him and
puck working together as much as i did
like that so you've got loki setting off
this entire mess so that she will track
down go after and ultimately yes kill
Morpheus and that more or less is the
film as she is just coming after him and
pulling things apart and Morpheus is
getting ready to face his own fate which
he does and of course along I haven't
talked about every character to be
introduced along the way
his sister death yeah she got introduced
basically in kind of the epilogue at the
very end of the first film so she's been
established that we can have a nice
touching moment with her when she comes
for him maybe we can get the other
endless in there in two seasons of Myst
at least showing them sort of having
them established and everything else but
also you know this will be a big build
climax he's dead and we also are kind of
gonna kind of roll in volume ten into
this which is the wake which is Daniel
taking over and taking on the mantle of
dream so we we get that so that it adds
to the tragedy that for everything his
mother went through to revenge for him
that she thought that is actually what
causes her to lose him because now he
has something else he has a mantle yes
responsibilities he can't be with her
anymore and it's it's a it's a note of
finality for the character of Morpheus
while still establishing that stories
keep going even though they change so
yeah I think there's actually aside from
you know a little bit of condensing a
little bit of trimming of a little fat
and a couple of character exercises like
puck that story requires almost no
change whatsoever you just do it
and then you would have a trilogy of
Sandman films and I think is incredibly
doable and what's really frustrating is
from what I read a couple of years back
there was at least one draft for a
Sandman film that was more or less what
I said that first one should be
specifically in terms of replacing dr.
destiny with the Corinthians so I'm not
the only one thinking of these things
I'm not claiming these are the most
original concepts in the world then no
one else could have possibly thought of
this I don't have a magic bullet I'm not
that pompous but come on this script
wise at the very least should not be
hard visually
yeah this is gonna be a lot of work
that's why I'm not gonna even bother
trying to think of direct okay fine I'll
throw out one guillermo del toro would
be friggin awesome but you know that
that's not a requirement there are other
directors who could do it as well if it
actually had gotten made a decade ago
back when it was when you know last sort
of cycle that they were working on in a
while back Terry Gilliam would have been
great so you know those kinds of
directors are who should be placed on
this I'm I know I said I wasn't gonna
talk directors I and that does not mean
of something gonna talk cast cuz I'm not
I absolutely am NOT I think ideally you
go with a chameleon character actor for
Morpheus of some kind because he is he
is not meant to have the inherent you
know charisma of a traditional leading
man you you could find a leading man
willing to do it I suppose but it's
gonna be tricky to not have whoever they
are override you know the character
because you know when I love Iron Man
but am i watching Tony Stark Graham I
watching Robert Downey jr. now I mean at
this point it's been doing it long
enough that I feel like it is a proper
character but you know it's a balance
it's tough to work sometimes but anyway
that'll do it so those are my thoughts
on how to adapt Neil Gaiman's Sandman to
film to a trilogy of films that I think
would work quite well what are your
thoughts on what I've said do you think
there is a better way to adapt this to
film do
you want to throw out some actual
casting ideas I know Joseph
gordon-levitt was set for a while he was
actually set up as a director originally
that would have been interesting but if
you have any thoughts on any part of
what I've just talked about drop
something down to comments let's talk
about it there's all that stuff to do if
you want to support the show even a
dollar a month it really helps there's a
patreon link there's a link to Twitter
there's a link to my podcast there's
links for a mess of things all down in
the description so until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]